tratemos de comprender la imagen general
de lo que sucede en esos mercados de
permutas de riesgo crediticio y vamos a
hablar de generalidades digamos que aquí
tenemos a la corporación a la
corporación ve la corporación ce
y digamos que tenemos bastantes personas
que compran estas permutas de riesgo
crediticio a los que llamaremos
aseguradores porque eso es lo que son en
esencia ellos aseguran sobre una deuda
las permutas de riesgo crediticio son
seguros que si alguien no paga cierta
deuda entonces esta compañía aseguradora
la va a pagar a cambio de compartirles
cierto porcentaje del interés de la
deuda digamos que aquí tenemos a la
aseguradora 1 la aseguradora 2 y algunas
de estas son compañías de seguros
algunos serán bancos aquí tenemos la
aseguradora 3 algunos incluso podrían
ser fondos de cobertura estas son las
personas que escriben las permutas de
riesgo crediticio y aquí están las
personas que de hecho compran las
permutas de riesgo crediticio en el
ejemplo anterior teníamos un fondo de
pensión que llamaremos pensión 1 aquí
tenemos otro fondo de pensión 2 y vamos
a redibujar
todas las conexiones que hay entre esas
organizaciones digamos que el fondo de
pensión uno le va a prestar dinero a la
corporación y le va a prestar mil
millones de dólares la corporación le va
a pagar al fondo de pensión 1 el 10 por
ciento de interés pero este fondo de
pensión uno quiere asegurarse de que va
a obtener el dinero de la corporación y
el dinero que le prestó ya que no pueden
prestarle dinero a cualquier corporación
que tenga una calificación crediticia
menor que estelar así que van a
asegurarse con la aseguradora 1 lo que
hacen es que de este 10 por ciento usan
algunos puntos base por ejemplo 100
puntos base y a cambio ellos reciben lo
que se le llama un seguro sobre esta es
una anotación que apenas estoy
inventando aquí y la razón por la que
esta aseguradora uno está participando
aquí es porque moody's les ha dado una
calificación crediticia muy alta así que
cuando ellos aseguran algo esencialmente
proporcionar más seguro
a todo este paquete de préstamo que se
le hizo a la corporación así que este
bono se vuelve un bono con calificación
doble a que es la calificación que tiene
la aseguradora 1 ya que si por alguna
razón la corporación
no pudiera devolverme el dinero que le
preste esta aseguradora me lo va a
devolver en su lugar y es más probable
por la calificación que tienen que la
corporación
se vaya a la bancarrota antes que la
aseguradora 1 por eso es que la
calificación de la aseguradora 1 es
mayor por lo que el riesgo del préstamo
que hicimos aquí ahora tiene una
categoría de riesgo tipo doble a que es
un riesgo mucho menor que el riesgo w
que es el que tiene la corporación y
bueno eso es lo que sucede aquí tenemos
la corporación ve y digamos que el fondo
de pensiones 2 quiere prestarle a la
corporación ve quizás dos mil millones
de dólares
y ellos reciben el 12 por ciento de la
cantidad prestada como interés pero de
nuevo este fondo de pensión 2 va con
esta aseguradora para asegurar el
préstamo para hacer la permuta del
riesgo crediticia así que aquí tienen un
seguro por ve y como es un poquito más
riesgoso pues hay que pagarles 200
puntos base y esto va del fondo de
pensiones 2 a la aseguradora 1 y de
hecho todo esto es un poquito peligroso
pensemos qué es lo que está sucediendo
siempre y cuando esta aseguradora uno no
disminuya su calificación crediticia que
fue hecha por alguna compañía
calificadora como moody's o alguna otra
puede seguir asegurando ese tipo de
deuda y no hay un límite por la cantidad
de deuda que pueden asegurar no existe
ley alguna que digan que no pueden
asegurar mil millones en deuda si ellos
no apartan mil millones para asegurar el
pago en caso de que esta corporación
no pueda pagar su deuda original y que
diga bueno en este caso tú como
aseguradora que sí
esta deuda debe de tener el efectivo
para poder pagar esta deuda en caso de
que falle la corporación a lo mismo en
este otro caso si se aseguran estos
200.000 millones de dólares no tienen
por qué apartarse del capital de la
compañía aseguradora estos 200 mil
millones que aseguró y lo que hacen
estas compañías aseguradoras es que
tienen un conjunto de personas que
empiezan a analizar la probabilidad de
que estas corporaciones vayan a la
bancarrota o no por lo que deben
mantener el capital suficiente para que
se cubra la estadística de que algunas
de las compañías que están asegurando se
vaya a la quiebra y no pueda pagar el
préstamo pero no tienen por qué mantener
el capital suficiente para respaldar
todas las deudas que están asegurando
así que ustedes pueden ver que aquí hay
un riesgo bastante interesante que pasa
si por cualquier razón alguna o todas de
estas corporaciones se van a la
bancarrota y no pueden pagar sus
préstamos pues de pronto ésta
aseguradora va a tener que pagar más
capital del que tiene en existencia y
aquí ya se cuestionaría la calificación
crediticia que tiene de doble a ya que
está realmente corriendo muchos riesgos
pero mientras estas compañías se
mantengan bien y no pase nada extraño
pues este es un negocio excelente ya que
solo están recolectando pagos por lo
asegurado sin tener que pagar ellos de
vuelta a nada ahora veamos otra variante
de esto estos fondos de pensiones fondos
de pensión 1 y fondo de pensión 2 están
motivados para asegurar sus préstamos a
estas corporaciones que no tienen el
nivel de riesgo suficiente como lo
establecen en sus respectivos contratos
de manera que el riesgo adicional se lo
están transfiriendo a la aseguradora al
comprar estas permutas de riesgo
crediticio lo que en esencia es una
póliza de seguro proporcionada por esta
aseguradora 1 pero podemos tener aquí
otro tercer actor y esto
no es menos legítimo en realidad podemos
tener aquí un fondo de cobertura 1 y
estos han hecho mucha investigación han
trabajado mucho y son un poquito más
sofisticados que los fondos de pensiones
1 y 2 y dicen sabes que esta compañía ve
no se ve muy fuerte que digamos yo
pienso que 200 puntos base de
probabilidad para que caiga la compañía
ve es algo bastante barato ya que yo
considero que hay una enorme
probabilidad de que la compañía ve se
vaya hacia abajo así que qué voy a hacer
bueno no le voy a prestar dinero a la
compañía ve ya que pienso que es muy
probable que salgan del negocio lo que
puedo hacer es comprar una permuta de
riesgo crediticio sobre la deuda de la
compañía ve en esencia me voy a asegurar
de que si ellos caen
yo voy a recibir algo sin tener que
haberles prestado dinero y esto lo voy a
hacer al comprar estas permutas a la
aseguradora 2 así que le pago a la
aseguradora 2 200 puntos base al año o
la cantidad que se considera
más adecuada para el valor de esta
permuta teniendo la casi certeza de que
esta compañía bs va a ir a la quiebra
digamos que en este caso son 200 puntos
base y digamos que esa aseguradora 2 ya
que yo estoy haciendo una apuesta muy
grande sobre esto me está dando
el seguro debe por 10.000 millones de
dólares
veamos qué es lo que está pasando aquí
aquí la compañía ve ni siquiera ha
pedido prestados estos 10.000 millones
así que de pronto tenemos este fondo de
cobertura que está comprando el seguro
de una deuda más grande de la que en
realidad tiene esta corporación ve ya
que realmente es un trato entre estos
dos actores nada más ya que la
aseguradora 2 dice bueno para mí es un
buen negocio porque estoy recibiendo 200
puntos base anuales por este seguro de
deuda de 10 mil millones y siempre que
esta compañía ve no se vaya a la quiebra
vergés voy a estar recibiendo esos
puntos base en cambio este fondo de
cobertura uno dice bueno yo estoy casi
seguro de que esta compañía bs va a ir a
la quiebra
así que si esto sucede pues va a ser un
buen negocio para mí ya que si ve se va
a la quiebra yo voy a recibir diez mil
millones de deuda debe que estoy
comprando de la aseguradora así que
veamos cuál es el 2 por ciento de 10 mil
millones así que aquí tenemos 200
millones de dólares
se le va a pagar 200 millones de dólares
por año a la aseguradora 2 quizás es un
número se ven un poco grandes pero quién
sabe existen fondos de cobertura que si
manejan estas cantidades tremendas de
miles de millones de dólares podría ser
que tuvieran justamente esta cantidad de
millones de dólares para pagar o lo que
es peor podrían no tener esta cantidad
de dinero pero pedirla prestada para
hacer este pago a la aseguradora ya que
están seguros de que va a colapsar y
están dispuestos a tomar este riesgo y a
lo mejor es una buena apuesta si ve se
va a la quiebra por ejemplo mañana qué
va a pasar bueno a lo mejor este fondo
de cobertura pago los 200 millones como
un primer pago a la aseguradora a lo
mejor pagó una fracción el primer
trimestre y durante los siguientes tres
meses ve se fue a la bancarrota así
estas personas del fondo de cobertura
recibieron 10 mil millones pero aquí
ocurre otra cosa interesante esta
aseguradora seguramente aseguró a otras
personas también y a otras corporaciones
con respecto a la deuda debe no sé igual
también aseguraron la deuda de a por
ejemplo así que qué sucede ve de pronto
se va a la bancarrota no puede pagar sus
deudas la aseguradora a uno le va a
deber al fondo de pensión dos por haber
asegurado la deuda debe la aseguradora 2
le va a deber a este fondo de cobertura
110 mil millones y bueno supongamos que
la aseguradora 2 tiene el dinero
suficiente para pagar esas pólizas de
seguro le paga el fondo de cobertura 1 y
a esos les va maravillosamente bien
tienen grandes bonos y todos se compran
yates pero a esta aseguradora de aquí
pues pagaron el dinero que debían pero
de pronto
moody's se está dando cuenta de lo que
está pasando esta agencia calificadora
se da cuenta de que esta aseguradora que
ya tuvo
pagar 10 mil millones y bueno eso es
sólo fue a una persona dudo que haya
sido la única persona que aseguraron
tuvieron que pagar mucho dinero y ahora
la aseguradora 2 ya no tiene capital
suficiente así que le van a bajar la
calificación crediticia de doble a que
era como estaba antes y ya que se tuvo
que dar toda esta cantidad de capital
tan tremenda moody's le cambia la
calificación aaa no se ve más aquí estoy
inventando calificaciones pero bueno
esto podría ocurrir a es mejor ve no lo
es tanto así que bueno le baja la
calificación pero de pronto cuando esta
aseguradora le bajan la calificación y
si esta aseguradora expidió pólizas
asegurando la deuda de otras
corporaciones a estos fondos de
pensiones de pronto lo que este fondo de
pensiones había prestado y que tenía
cierto nivel crediticio que cumplía con
sus especificaciones pues ya no lo tiene
ya que esta aseguradora que antes era
doble a y que cumplía con las
especificaciones de nivel de riesgo para
de pensión 2 pues ya no la tiene ya le
bajaron la calificación y este fondo de
pensión solo puede invertir en compañías
con calificación crediticia de a mayor
por lo que este fondo de pensiones va a
tener que deshacer esa transacción del
préstamo que se le hizo a la otra
compañía cuya deuda fue asegurada por la
aseguradora 2 va a tener que descargar
esa deuda que fue asegurada por el hecho
de que la compañía se fue a la quiebra
si la aseguradora 2 pierde esa
calificación y había asegurado deuda de
la corporación
pues ya no la va a poder mantener con la
calificación doble a por lo que con que
falle una compañía o una corporación
vamos a tener esta reacción en cadena en
donde bueno se va a la quiebra esta
compañía la aseguradora tiene que pagar
las pólizas de la deuda de la compañía
que acaba de quebrar se queda sin
capital le bajan la calificación
crediticia y todas las demás pólizas que
tenía asegurada de otras compañías pues
esas pólizas ya no van a tener la
calificación doble a bava
su calificación por lo que los fondos de
pensiones que sólo podían tener
inversiones con compañías con
calificación de aún mayor pues ya no van
a poder tener estas inversiones ya que
bajó la calificación y van a tener que
recuperar ese préstamo así que ahora la
corporación
pues va a perder todos los préstamos que
le hicieron y que estaban asegurados por
estas aseguradoras sé que esto es
bastante confuso pero todo esto es para
ayudarles a comprender lo que dijo
warren buffett acerca de las permutas de
riesgo crediticio junto con otras
herramientas financieras como armas
financieras de destrucción masiva ya que
se tienen muchas personas que no
tuvieron que mantener el capital para
asegurar las deudas que estaban
respaldando y se tienen a muchas
personas que están haciendo este tipo de
apuestas con dos suposiciones
fundamentales primero que las
calificaciones de estas agencias
calificadoras son válidas y que las
otras personas tienen el dinero para
respaldar las pólizas aseguradas pero si
de pronto encontramos que una cosa falla
en él
sistema pues vamos a tener toda una
cascada de problemas de baja de
calificaciones en lo que resulta que
pues la gente no tiene el dinero
suficiente para respaldar los préstamos
o las cantidades aseguradas